hey guys welcome to the behind the
scenes or how he made the music we went
to a recording studio called point of
blue studios pob studios calm run by a
guy named Alex Reeves really cool guy
really nice really knows what he's doing
so any ule artists out there looking to
record some music
check them out anyways sit back and
enjoy the tomfoolery
muga check alright
they might hi guys were here at point of
lose two wheels with Alex grieves he's a
man responsible for music sounded good
helping us with recording and mixing
process Alex how long have you been
doing this for I've been doing it since
I was like 10 years old my dad's
recording engineer I had studio when I
was 10 that's cool
that's pretty awesome let's go check it
out hey guys come on in check out my
studio oh no way
huh Nico very good hey hey sorry we beat
you you got a nice place here Alex
yeah Nick are you ready to rock yeah
yeah a lot of guys are probably
wondering Sam you guys report a lot of
music yourself why don't you just do
that instead of go to a studio well you
see when you're doing live recordings
you need a lot of like very specialized
equipment specialized microphones for
your guitars bass drums and also preamps
which kind of give the instruments a
special sound going into the recorder
[Music]
now when you're recording the drums you
have a microphone on almost every single
drum to get the best sound and a
professional studio that's what you can
get yeah
[Music]
name your instrument all of his bad luck
not to have a name for any of your
guitars such relics yeah what's his name
here mixing board Suzi we gotta get
everybody set up we got the drums in the
booth today we're going to isolate those
but basically we're going to go down the
line do a scratch track with everything
path the band play live go in and then
overdub everything on top of that
scratch track is just a quick one time
through live with the band playing all
the parts okay that we can use this
reference when we go back and and record
all the individual parts all right we're
going to record this fresh tracks
[Music]
but yeah I'll recovering is going back
and clattering in guitar/bass all the
parts individually separately and
isolated under their own separate tracks
so we can mix it better later
[Music]
uh-huh all right one more time I messed
up the last note
[Music]
this song is dedicated she Jake Watson I
want to smooch you
smoochie smoochie
[Music]
I know the devil's Empire I feel the
hunger inside I know he's coming after
me yeah and the ones you think you need
grows smaller every day that you without
me that's really good what
anything that's good that's it yeah I'm
gonna get it boy survived I'm second
[Music]